이전 예와 같은 두 유니터리 gate가 있고, 여기 이 기호들은 표준 기저 측정을 나타내요.
구체적으로, 두 유니터리 연산이 수행된 후에
Y에 대해 표준 기저 측정이 수행돼요.
그리고 결과가 고전적 비트 B에
덮어씌워지고, 마찬가지로 X가 측정되고 그 결과가 비트 A에 기록돼요.
여기서 qubit X와 Y가 측정된 후에도 계속되는 것을 볼 수 있어요.
하지만 측정된 후의 qubit에 대해
그다지 신경 쓰지 않는 경우가 꽤 흔해요.
때때로 우리가 관심 있는 것은
측정 결과뿐이에요. 그런 경우에는 여기 보이는
약식 스타일을 사용할 수 있어요.
측정에 qubit이 들어가고 고전적 비트가 나오는 형태예요.
여기서의 이해는 qubit이 측정되면
그냥 버려지거나 무시되고 고전적 측정
결과가 앞으로 전달된다는 거예요.
시리즈가 계속되면서, quantum circuit의
많은 예를 보게 될 건데, 방금 본
매우 간단한 예보다 훨씬 더 복잡할 거예요.
앞서 언급했듯이, 다른 gate에는
다른 기호가 사용돼요.
단일 qubit gate는 보통 어떤 연산인지
나타내는 글자가 적힌 사각형으로 표시돼요.
때때로 이런 다양한 gate들이
다른 의미를 나타내기 위해 색으로 구분되기도 하지만,
지금은 그것을 무시할게요.
이미 Controlled NOT gate를
봤어요.
스왑 gate는 여기 보이는 것처럼
표시되고, Toffoli gate와 Fredkin gate는
여기 보이는 것처럼 표시돼요.
Toffoli gate는 제어된 Controlled NOT gate이고 Fredkin gate는
제어된 스왑 gate라는 것을 기억하세요.
그래서 이 기호들은 제어 qubit이
gate를 제어하는 선으로 연결된 채워진 원으로
표시된다는 아이디어와 일치해요.
일반적으로, 제어 qubit이
꼭 위에 있을 필요는 없고, 이 gate들이
인접한 qubit에만 작용할 필요도 없어요. 즉, 이 gate들이
작용하지 않는 다른 qubit들을 가로질러
늘어날 수 있고, 이후 수업에서 그런 경우를 볼 거예요.
quantum circuit 모델을 사용할 때 자주 하는 한 가지 더는 임의의 유니터리 연산을
임의의 수의 qubit에 대해
여기 보이는 것처럼 단일 gate로 보는 거예요.
유니터리 연산이 무엇이든 그에 해당하는
레이블이 있는 직사각형을 그리면 돼요.
이 경우에는 어떤
유니터리 연산 U예요.
물론 이 다이어그램에서 U가 무엇인지는
알 수 없고, U가 어떻게든 정의되어 있다고 가정하거나
어떤 임의의
유니터리 연산 U를 고려하고 있다고 생각해야 해요. 예를 들어 명확성을 위해
U를 서브루틴으로 생각하고 싶을 수도 있어요.
여기 보이는 이 표기법도
사용하는데, 제어 U 연산을 위한 것이에요.
이전처럼 제어 qubit은 채워진 원으로 표시돼요.
quantum circuit 모델에 대한 간단한 소개였어요.
앞서 말했듯이, quantum circuit의 더 많은 예를
시리즈를 계속하면서 보게 될 거예요.
수업의 다음 부분에서는 내적,
직교정규성, 그리고 사영에 대해 살펴볼 건데, 이것들은 매우 중요한 개념이에요.
양자 정보와 계산에서요.
내적부터 시작할게요.
디랙 표기법을 사용할 때 Ket은
열 벡터이고 Bra는 행 벡터라는 것을 기억하세요.
구체적으로, 주어진 열 벡터에 대응하는
Bra 벡터는 그 열 벡터의 켤레 전치예요.
여기 이 벡터에 대해, 벡터를 행렬처럼
전치해서 대응하는 Bra 벡터를 구하는데,
이것은 옆으로 눕히고 각 성분의 복소 켤레를 취하는 것이에요.
이제, 이렇게 같은 수의 성분을 가진 두 Ket이 있다고 가정해요.
여기 이 브래킷을 형성하면, 이것은 단순히
Bra와 Ket의 곱을 행렬처럼 취하는 것인데,
여기 보이는 이 식을 얻게 돼요.
이것은 스칼라, 즉 복소수예요.
이 값을 이 두 벡터의
내적이라고 불러요.
벡터가 표준 기저 벡터의
선형 결합으로 표현된 형태의 벡터에 대해서도
내적을 생각할 수 있어요.
표준 기저 벡터들의 선형 결합이에요.
이 벡터들의 내적은 이전과 같은 방식으로 정의돼요.
Bra Psi 곱하기 Ket Phi인데, 이렇게
곱으로 표현할 수 있어요.
계산하고 정리하면, 내적에 대한 여기 이 식이 남는데, 이전에 있던 것과 유사해요.
다만 이번에는 고전적 상태 집합의
원소에 대해 합을 취하는데, 이 경우에는 시그마예요.
여기 내적이 어떻게 작동하는지에 대한
기하학적 그림을 보여주는 예가 있어요.
qubit에 해당하는 2차원 공간에
원을 그렸는데, 실수 성분을 가진
벡터로 제한하는 한
이 평면 위의 점으로 그릴 수 있어요.